ok vamos a empezar con una comunidad con
cada uno si usted se presenta que su
nombre y donde vive y bueno es eso lo
que quiere
me llamo ser él
es un nombre francés pero no sé no sé
por qué
y bueno soy estudiante de español en la
universidad de yale que está en el
noreste de inglaterra y bueno me encanta
idiomas y todo
empecé a usar el link hace unas semanas
y me gusta mucho
bueno
pero si soy yo
y buena profesional soy judío son de mis
hijos
pero hay muy difícil entender mucho ego
xxi
técnico de clases que te parece bueno
pues soy julio soy de méxico vivo en la
ciudad de méxico y pues bueno mis
intereses son los idiomas y también me
gusta mucho la historia la cultura y
bueno estudio actualmente de negocios
internacionales
gracias yo soy
una doble ley con marc mi hijo también
me gusta mucho los idiomas
me gusta viajar historia
y beber vino y comer y después
las madres después la pared
bueno es que
esta mayor y creo amar ya marx
estás
me extrañó lo es bueno voy a escuchar ok
por favor bueno muy bien pero podemos
ver tu cara
porque solamente vemos una pared y la
frente y la prenden te tienes que
ajustar el camera el ángulo o la
pantalla del portátil vemos
muy bien muy bien
buenos días dónde vives en qué ciudad
mar
ah
frente a las otras volver amar bueno yo
técnica el sueco y me encantan los
idiomas llevó aproximadamente cuatro
años estudiando español y el próximo año
yo voy a moverme a españa a las palmas
para estudiar traducción e
interpretación en la universidad
y bueno
y roberto bueno yo soy roberto soy
mexicano y vivo en guadalajara
mis padres mis dos grandes pasiones son
los idiomas y las ciencias biológicas
muy bien y eduardo a
julio
yo dijo que eduardo sea junto al grupo
después es 8 ok
bueno y también me parece que hay
problemas técnicos ok de qué
queréis disfrutar podemos discutir
libremente del aprendizaje de idiomas
podemos seguir tenéis algunas preguntas
sobre el link
yo puedo también mostrar por ejemplo
la utilización de la página
lección porque hay también aquí esta
posibilidad de demostrar bueno de ser
springer si quieres entonces empezando
con él tienes algo de textiles de
algunas preguntas sobre link o sobre el
aprendiz el aprendizaje de idiomas
bueno tengo un poquito un poquito de
ayuda
dt link porque no sé cómo importar
textos para usar yo solo hay nadie más
bueno así que como como hago eso
yo he hecho una importación
bueno hay dos maneras para importar
primero bueno aquí
es lo que aquí tenemos y vamos a cambiar
lingua porque bueno español español
porque yo estoy estudiando checo pero
ahora y coreano pero vamos a ver el
italiano ok
como como sabéis la primera página es la
página para aprender
y allí tienes puedes yo voy a explicar
un poco más que simplemente de la
creación que youtube es preguntado vale
aquí podemos ajustar pero aquí es un
listo para ver las cosas que quieres
hacer enseguida entonces yo normalmente
aquí
quiero ver las lecciones en el idioma
que estoy estudiando si vosotros han
recomendado lecciones que han recibido
rosas y aquí vemos por ejemplo el
journal y no
joan borrasca de bamba aunque tiene
cuatro rosas bueno pues por eso pero si
no quieres estudiar o bien una elección
recomienda recomendar a un curso
recomendado puedes también importar lo
más rápido para importar es ir a las
tareas tags y aquí tienes las tres
últimas lecciones que has estudiado y
también puedes importar aquí ya no
puedes usar para escribir
sin importar
si vas
a la biblio a la biblioteca también
tienes un botón para importar que los
dos son iguales pero aquí es más rápido
porque voy atrás importa verse algo clic
aquí tengo
soy en italiano tengo que describir
decidir porque tengo ya
colección cursos en italiano vengo a
pedir en que voy a añadir esta lección
importada si bien es nuevo pero hay
cambiar la selección and quiere decir
que este artículo de un periódico o lo
que sea será importada por tipo estado y
diputado como lección única y no va a
tener parte de un curso pero es más así
por ejemplo si yo voy a un periódico
checo
yo voy crear un curso del periódico
checo bueno y después todos los datos
los artículos yo voy a añadir a la
colección a este curso
aquí bueno hay que hay que hacer bueno
después tiene que ir a la página en el
ue en el web y copiar todo el artículo
y que después haz click aquí la 6ta
visite en español paste pegar superior
en este que pegar y después normalmente
yo cuando hago una copia de un artículo
del per de un periódico
bueno pues puedo hacerlo por ejemplo si
yo voy
al día
porque aquí tengo algo en checo pero no
importa voy a copiar esto incluso con el
título
aquí y luego vengo y todos los gráficos
desaparecen y después necesito también
el título
y después si yo quiero compartir este
artículo con mis amigos que están
estudiando checo si yo puedo también
sin compartir en la biblioteca porque yo
no tengo el derecho de compartir
artículos
de un periódico con los miembros
abiertamente en la biblioteca no puedo
hacerlo pero uno a uno lo puedo hacer
entonces yo voy a copiar
el lugar y ponerlo aquí
yo puedo hacer una descripción si quiero
pero si es privado no vas a tener una
descripción porque ya entonces y después
yo hago
o bien sea como quieres ahora está
importado privado
y si yo quería
compartir en la biblioteca
ya está abierto aquí estamos y todo está
en azul porque es un artículo checo en
la sección italiano sí entonces
solamente una palabra que es como un al
checo y al italiano aparece en amarillo
pero si yo quiero compartir esta lección
en la biblioteca inscripción en
principio no tengo el de la de la
derecha de hetero pero aquí vas a ser
disc lección y después puedes seguir las
instrucciones instrucciones para
compartir en la biblioteca
si debo hay aquí qué
todos los miembros
que no apagan los miembros gratis y hay
un límite solamente pueden importar 5
lecciones pero si estás miembro pagando
10 dólares al mes puedes importar una
cantidad ilimitada de todos los hijos
aunque pero si si tu crees una lección
pero ningún español si tú haces una
discusión con tu amigo en español sobre
la vida en guadalajara el que quieres
compartir en la biblioteca para ayudar a
los alumnos que están estudiando español
esta es libre de este límite éste no
cuenta entonces tú puedes añadir tantas
lecciones que quieres si tú
estas elecciones las comparte el pp que
sí sí sí es la de las cejas en la
biblioteca para nosotros
ok sí bueno bueno
hay otros que creo que vamos a comentar
puede escuchar
hablo
un poquito en todo siento
estás la bienvenida jorge
niklas tengo una pregunta sobre sobre lo
que has explicado
por ejemplo en wikipedia o algo así
que tiene varias varios
nos llama
fuentes d
del texto se puede compartir o no
tenemos la permisión de wikipedia para
compartir sus artículos bueno entonces
cualquier artículo de cooper ya si tú
tienes quieres añadir tu voz
por ejemplo en sueco lo puedes compartir
en la biblioteca sueca o española o lo
que sea
si bien ok otra pregunta si cuando un
idioma por ejemplo un idioma detecta
hasta cuándo estará en el beta o sea
cuando sea
templada a idiomas
originales y sostenido vemos que tenemos
ley idiomas sostenidos que no son
soportados que no nosotros por ejemplo
si vas a la biblioteca en turco es ya en
pocas cosas en la biblioteca es el caso
que tenemos algunas cosas pero no como
en inglés español francés y alemán bueno
nosotros normalmente si es alemán o otro
vamos a preocuparnos porque turistas
miembros está pagando diga hombre yo
pago para aprender turco y no hay nada
en la biblia no hay muy pocas cosas
nosotros digamos es un idioma beta no
tenemos la responsabilidad aunque pero
si alguien dice para mí estoy el [ __ ]
alemán y quiero aprender turco x quiero
añadir un diccionario o tal esto lo
vamos a hacer
pero en principio no queremos hacer
demasiado porque tenemos mucho trabajo
que hacer en cada trabajo aún algo muy
sencillo es mucho con todo es porque hay
siempre crees te quiere otro y tenemos
que limitarnos si no no no podemos hacer
nada entonces yo no si hay mucha gente
que están estudiando por ejemplo el
finlandés o sí sí ahí como pero si tú
vas a mirar la gente que está en los
idiomas betas son muy pocos entonces
tenemos mucha gente muchos miembros y
están estudiando español francés alemán
japonés tenemos que soportar esos
miembros miembros pero hay muy pocos que
están estudiando esperanto no voy a
pasar mi tiempo a ayudar a la gente que
está en espera estudiando es verdad pero
aquí pero si hay mil personas que están
estudiando esperanto vamos a hacer
esperado en hacerlo un idioma suspendido
un influjo de personas según el mercado
y la exigencia de nuestros miembros una
otra cosa quiero añadir antes de hablar
antes de julio de vuelo de vuelta bueno
bienvenido
a hablar con el sujeto es que la
importación hay una u otra manera de
importar y voy a demostrar otra vez
bueno es que hay lo que se llama el
bookmarklet
si yo voy vamos a ver vamos a un vamos a
la estampa porque estamos en italiano no
estamos en checo
y si yo quiero importar este artículo
bueno yo pues puedo
existen
y después tengo un informe
mike leigh en cuerpo makled y yo puedo
aplicar sobre el import bachman y
el idioma de ejercitar ya no importa
y este es más rápido
tiene un otro una otra ventaja es que si
haces la importación con el import
bookmarklet l el enlace la embate el
enlace correo ya está
entonces es muy fácil compartir por
ejemplo está este ritmo en italiano si
yo quiero compartir
d
aquí el enlace ya está entonces todos
mis amigos
a la gente le gusta elegir friends o
público o solo mis amigos no puedo
compartir este artículo pero sin la
necesidad de copiar y pegar el enlace
julio a
no es roberto y después julio roberto
aunque bueno yo no conozco el link y
nunca me he inscrito a la página por lo
tanto mi conocimiento sobre el link es
muy prácticamente nulo
pero tengo una pregunta se pueden
estudiar varios idiomas al mismo tiempo
con una suscripción básica de 10 dólares
o tengo un límite de lecciones no con
cuando tienes membresía directo reserves
idiomas quieres
pues en este momento estoy interesado en
estudiar a alemany y por alemán
portugués y más adelante japonés pero si
es posible si yo lo estoy estudiando
estoy estudiando checo ruso porque cada
día para no olvidar mi checo y mi luso
voy a importar algunos artículos del
checo y luso después estoy estudiando
coreano lo que quiero refrescar mi
alemán o mi español
debo añadir que la gran ventaja de pagar
los los 10 dólares es que tienes un
nombre ilimitado
desde el ics y si yo por ejemplo voy a
mí
en un tiempo por ejemplo si yo voy a una
una lección que estoy estudiando vamos a
demostrar ser otra vez
si voy hay una lección por ejemplo
en breve
tengo un montón de links amarillo por
ejemplo si es este que me ayuda a
aprender las palabras cualquier cada vez
que voy a
cada vez que voy a
importar o estudiar algo hay
hay tantas palabras que ya he buscado en
el diccionario y la primera vez que
buscas algo en el diccionario que va a
olvidar no es posible recordar ese del
sentido de la palabra pero así cada vez
hay la palabra en amarillo con los
ejemplos y así es para mí es es
necesario si solamente tienes 100 porque
hay un límite límite
por los miembros que no pagan solamente
pueden salvar
10 100 palabras sus frases en su base de
datos
en checo en ruso
tengo como 30 mil palabras links creador
salvado entonces tengo esas esas
palabras esos amigos amarillos que me
ayuden
la ayuda a aprender para aprender
palabras aunque esté con también con la
y me queda importación ilimitada son las
gran ventaja es del 26 para otra
pregunta
steve con respecto a las palabras
subrayadas en amarillo quiere decir que
las ya las aprendí aunque lo que quiere
decir la mayor exactamente
bueno si yo es porque el sonido era un
poco difícil quieres o quiere saber las
palabras en el mar amarillo que quieren
12 que quiere decir lo amarillo que ya
es una palabra que entendió no es una
palabra que
ya ha buscado en el diccionario
nada más nada más pero hay cuatro etapas
cuatro estatus que uno quiere decir que
new es una palabra nueva
acabo de buscar en el diccionario acabo
de ponerlo de mi paso de datos y nada
más
que no me acuerdo pero ya está un poco
mejor porque ya no es nuevo y cuando
cambias por ejemplo miremos este es un 1
no vi ok
puedo cambiar cambiando el número si
cambio se cambia también el color ahora
tenemos un amarillo menos profundo menos
menos amarillo y 3 aún mejor ni cuatro y
ya no está amarillo pero está como
existe
online se ha subrayado un rayado dañado
subrayado entonces hay una progresión
porque como sabemos nosotros las
palabras es una progresión gradual la
primera vez que encontrás la palabra y
no quieres tienes como una idea y por
eso con nosotros digamos que la
explicación una tradición y solamente
una indicación de la significación del
sentido porque aprender a utilizarlo
esta palabra aparece con palabras
siempre lo mismo
esos ejemplos son muy útiles para mí
porque muchas veces hay siempre las
mismas palabras que van a aparecer
juntos con esta palabra y desde este
modo se va
poco a poco conociendo esta jornada
price un día puedes utilizar las
palabras
aunque de acuerdo
hay otra otra pregunta
con cuánta frecuencia usas como lashkars
para aprender las palabras
es muy individual yo - parece que
trabajan con las frescas cada día una
hora una hora y medio cada día para mis
idiomas y aquí estoy tratando de
aprender presidió cosas que son
agradables para mí
yo prefiero leer y escuchar el programa
cómo aprendes las palabras entonces
yo debo añadir que de vez en cuando voy
a hacerlas las corts aquí en la lección
es decir antes de leer leer la lección o
después de haber leído la lección
voy a hacer una revisión con partners
también si estás estoy porque yo utilizo
mucho la aplicación hay link si entro
porque yo lo tengo conmigo y siempre
puede o bien leer y tengo las solas las
palabras que pueden aparecer por la
palabra son conocidos políticas pero
también puedo revisar mis más carácter
pero yo te digo francamente si tú yo leo
mucho y esas palabras
en amarillo y sen sin hacerlas frescas
entre a la cabeza entre la cabeza si yo
tenía cinco días de cinco horas al día
para aprender idiomas para variar un
poco las actividades yo creo que también
las que se haría más tiempo con los
rascas pero tengo como una hora o nueve
medio y yo prefiero porque yo no tengo
en examen no tengo ninguna obligación y
yo hago las cosas agradables para mí
entonces es muy individual si lo veo
aunque hay otra pregunta
y
no puedo por ejemplo hacer una
explicación también de la biblioteca
cómo buscar cosas
necesario
e
y bueno bueno entonces tenemos cuatro
posibilidades la biblioteca son las
cosas que todavía no has visto no has
visto en la biblioteca vamos vamos
las cosas que no conoces por qué
esperamos
lo que vamos a el mar
tenemos biblioteca miami lecciones son
las lecciones que ya ha escogido
pero ese mismo lugar y éste hace que un
poco
main porque son las cosas importados
entonces siempre puede ir buscar nuevas
lecciones a las regiones que están
estudiando
y vamos a la biblioteca ese mismo lugar
solamente es la vista es diferente o
bien vemos que no es que escogió y
puedes ver lecciones
éste quiere decir que es yo puedo
agregar un playlist por ejemplo
esta elección ahora no voy a estudiarlo
pero un día quiero explicarlo voy a
añadir a mi playlist leyes por ejemplo
las elecciones estructuras de historia
voy a buscar algunas cosas que tienen
que ver con esto y voy a añadir esta
lección a este
pues yo ya he creado y también a alguien
de nosotros si quiere a ayudar a los
miembros que están estudiando español
algunas lecciones que son para
principiantes
este es un playlist de junio para
principiantes y atrás puedes crear tú
mismo y añadir algunas otras lecciones
de otra persona
es vélez para ayudar a criticar lección
para principiantes sobre méxico porque
es un pre listo y también puedes cambiar
aquí el nivel pero normalmente el nivel
de dificultad lo debe tener decidir en
la página aprender es aquí que tú puedes
determinar el nivel y este es el nivel
que será siempre el nivel en la
biblioteca pero cuando estás en la
biblioteca puedes cambiar de nivel pero
la próxima vez que vas a la biblioteca
será al nivel que ya tuve ha determinado
en la página aprender por qué porque no
puedo no podemos cambiar y en que el
sistema se acuerdo de todas las
los cambios no entonces con la para
elegir el nivel de dificultad de la
biblioteca es en la página aprender aquí
puedes ver a la biblioteca en dos
columnas o un punto y éste según según
tu ordenador sirve muchas cosas hay
gente que tienen las lecciones
o
y de la tabla
soy yo
y
el sistema va a acordar se va a colar
sede de la selección que tú has hecho
aquí puedes importante
y tú puedes buscar según la cantidad de
rosas es decir las lecciones más
populares
llegó cuando por ejemplo
aquí tenemos cuando están estas
elecciones
añadido abierta
y bueno bien según el alfabeto el orden
alfabético sí
o bien si hay también otros maneras
puede por ejemplo buscar según el
porcentaje de palabras nuevas según la
duración del audio
una cantidad de recursos por ejemplo
solamente elecciones que tienen vídeos
lecciones que tienen ejercicios que
tienen traducciones o que hay categorías
hay tipos hay acentos por ejemplo es
alemán quieres solamente
pero lecciones con el acento alemán ya
vienen de austria
entonces hay una otra cosa y me gusta
mucho
guiadas por irene por ejemplo puede
explicar sobre su nombre y todo
únicamente lecciones de irene van a
ofrecer aparecer
bueno también puedes ver solamente las
lecciones que estás estudiando
y también los archivos ok
hay cuestiones sobre la biblioteca
como otras cosas gracias
puedes buscar aquí en el ser vox porque
por ejemplo yo no sé si es economía y
puedes
en alemán
que ya existe
lo que yo no tengo en mis elecciones
pero vamos en la biblioteca
dónde
en el chat
aquí estamos ok en direcciones no había
elección son más económicas pero en la
biblioteca tenemos entonces este también
es una manera para buscar
ok y filtros avanzados también como
filtros avanzados
aquí tienes que explicar y aquí tenemos
los filtros avanzados
entonces si quiero solamente ver bueno
pero tengo por ejemplo ahora voy a
buscar otra vez tenemos qué
quieres decir
para ver por ejemplo
solamente entre 5 y 10 por ciento o 2
ante 5 mil 15 de palabras nuevas
vamos a ver lo que entonces puedes
concentrarte a cosas a un nivel de
dificultad
para ti qué es lo que quieres
por ejemplo
y hay otras preguntas sobre él
o comentarlos yo tengo una pregunta
usted también básicamente lo que nos
estás mostrando en este momento es el
link 2.0 no te el cual es la diferencia
o cuáles son las diferentes entre el
entre esta nueva versión del link y la
anterior lo mate digamos los highlights
los que son
una biblioteca que para mí es mucho más
fácil buscar cosas
y también tenía tenemos teníamos algunos
problemas al principio pero es mucho
segunda que es la organización la
navegación ha cambiado completamente
de la versión anterior teníamos mucho
más botones
hemos tratado de simplificar la
aplicación entonces amigos amigos pues
cambiamos
hemos también cambiado el sistema para
como como seguir a amigos como a poner
el diseño puedes por ejemplo en la
sección y aquí lo que no era posible
anterior anteriormente
eso me quite
audio audio audio
audio por ejemplo yo voy a hablar en el
de bronce en checo y voy ponerlo puedes
añadir
pero sin vidrios ok
por ejemplo para mostrar tu progreso en
el idioma que estás aprendiendo bueno
este es completamente rey organizado
puede ser en la página amigos puede
buscar todo por ejemplo solo
a los amigos que están estudiando
coreano victoriano
para ver las tres últimas elecciones
en alemán que nunca voy
muy raro y estudiado además de buscar la
última lección que ha abierto y la
navegación a muchos cambiado en la
página en la página lección
y este muy importante porque hay hay dos
maneras de estudiar en la página lección
o bien como yo lo hago yo voy a cambiar
las palabras azules en palabras de
amarillas en la primera cosa que hago lo
hago muy rápido porque yo prefiero leer
estudiar cuando todas las palabras son
amarillas pero otros prefieren leer y
salvar palabras a la vez porque pero voy
a mostrar cómo hago yo entonces yo voy
porque éste no este no es una palabra o
ex pupilo blake no nos la obliga no voy
a salvarlo
ok multi biden d ok
steve este yo tengo una pregunta
entonces las palabras azules quieren
decir que son palabras que yo ya conozco
o como qué significan exactamente cuando
la palabra estás subrayada en azul
creo que es decir meditaba
uy no hay que esperarlo está bien hay
que esperarlo un poquito sí
las palabras azules son nuevas que no
has visto general
o sea que son palabras que no he visto
sí sí
a de acuerdo gracias bien
e
bueno